[Music]
welcome back time now for the press
preview our first look at the front
pages as they arrive uh let's see what's
making the headlines with the columnist
cara malone and the editor of the
courier david clegg carol will be there
i am reliably informed in just a moment
they'll be with us from now until just
before midnight but let's take you
through the front pages that we have uh
starting with the daily telegraph it
leads with owen patterson's resignation
as an mp amidst conservative anger at
number 10's handling of sleaze
allegations against him
the front of the metro has the same
story their headline tory odengo see
what they did there
tories plunged into crisis after sleaze
rules u-turn uh at the front of the
guardian they're also covering uh owen
patterson's resignation
the eye the same story the headline day
of chaos in downing street
the yorkshire post headline reads this
uh sponsors ditch club as racism scandal
deepens
as yorkshire county cricket club is
banned from hosting international
matches
the ft uh you might expect it to go this
way leads with the bank of england
sending investors scrambling by keeping
interest rates on hold
turning out to the daily mirror they
have a different lead entirely asking
the question how many more victims
in response to david fuller who admitted
murdering two young women
and the daily mail also leading on the
daily david fuller story with the words
horror
at the morgue
as mentioned we are joined tonight at by
david click shortly at carol malone
david good to see you it's just you and
i for the moment anyway um so let's dive
straight on in shall we um the front
page of the metro the story
frankly i've had a slightly later start
than i usually do i didn't watch the
breakfast news this morning looked at
the news at around about half 11.
frankly i i've seen some pretty
dangerous and bad days for governments
in my time this is up there
i can't remember quite such a
shambles uh even with a government
that's been prone to the occasional
shambles it really was an extraordinary
day today from
uh last night's uh seeming belief that
this was a kind of stunt they could pull
to how quickly they capitulated through
the course of today it really it really
has been a today episode and many of the
newspapers are leading on it today and i
think the concerning thing for boris
johnson and the conservative government
will be is that they are not finding any
allies anywhere in the press
or wider media as far as i can see the
the wide consensus is that they should
never have tried to to pull this stunt
to get owen patterson off uh it was it
showed a remarkable lack of judgment it
showed that they don't think the rules
should apply to them uh and that
also i think they they they seem to have
been surprised by the strength of
feeling in the public reaction there's a
bullet point on the cover of the eye
tomorrow which is uh also covering the
story on the front page which says that
they were taken aback by the reaction
which just just just as incred and seems
an incredible misreading of the public
mood and the sense of right and wrong
that the public tend to have that they
could have miscalculated so badly here
and it does feel to me like something
that is going to have cut through
something that i think speaks to the
character of the government speaks to
the character of the prime minister uh
and
i think could could end up really
hurting their reputation
i pleased to say david that carol has
joined us good to see you carol i mean
what what do you make of all of this no
matter how the government tries to spin
it this was a crunching gear change
u-turn i mean whatever analogy you want
to use it's embarrassing does not come
close to describing
this too right you know i haven't seen
this kind of
parliamentary chicanery um since brexit
before that the expenses scandal and you
know then back then we saw the greed the
fraud the sheer refrontery of mps
thinking it was fine to spend taxpayers
money on moats and and and plasma tvs
but this
is taking us right back it's like
they've learned nothing you know mps now
have no more respect for us now than
they had back then they said that this
sort of stuff would never happen again
now it is you know there there no
principle the tory government is
supposed to be the standard bearer for
for the rule of law this is not this is
this is then changing the rules to try
and get one of their their people out of
a mess you know it's literally
sticking two fingers up with the
electorate and saying you know the rules
don't apply to us and and and i mean i
just heard the tail end of what david
was saying there he's absolutely right
you know boris backed owen patterson on
this and you know the government was
whipped into voting to change these
rules which is it's astonishing he
doesn't understand his own mps his own
parliament enough to know that there
would be opera over this you know if if
this if this the standards bodies were
so bad why wait till now to change them
why weren't they changed before you know
this woman that they're they're all
going on about catherine stone may well
be auntie tory anti-brexit and
anti-burst and all the rest of it but
why wait till now to have a go there
when i when patterson is in trouble he
didn't know he had to go he has gone
he's still not really accepting
responsibility for all of this he's
saying it's all a big mistake and he's
totally innocent which you know the
committee says he's
not but this is a dark dark day not just
for the government but for democracy i i
do want to move on to another story in
just a second so briefly if you can
david i mean what's the mistake that the
conservatives made in all of this
conflating the two issues because i know
from conversations i've had with mps on
the other side of the chamber that there
is a desire amongst a substantial group
of parliamentarians to to reform this
process
yeah i mean i think that has been one of
the mistakes they made interestingly the
scottish conservative leader douglas
ross
dodged the vote yesterday and when i was
speaking to him yesterday and asked him
why why he hadn't voted it was that that
was the reason that he gave that he
didn't think the two things should be
tied in that the wider questions about
the process should be separated from the
specific case but i think actually it's
it's a more endemic problem than that
it's not a one-off it's not a mistake on
process
i i i feel that you know the the simple
truth of the matter is is that we have a
prime minister who's spent his life uh
getting away with not having to take
responsibility for the consequences of
his actions and he feels that that is a
charmed life he leads and is surprised
when he finds out that some actions will
actually have consequences i'm afraid
that is the overall message from from
this episode as far as i can see
carol the the front of the the daily
mirror today just every so often a story
comes along that stops you in its tracks
just because of the the detail contained
around the story of david fuller frankly
is one of those
it is and you've got to forgive me
because i've only just received this
stuff from you guys but um yeah it's a
this look this was for 34 years of this
guy who is now was one of britain's most
prolific sex offenders believed he had
got away with the murder of two women
and the sexual assault of dozens of
corpses it was only after the
breakthrough of dna sample that led
detectives to him it is astonishing you
know he's um
the the 2009 reinvestigation was boosted
by an enhanced dna sample from from one
of his victims types but the fact that
he got away with this for so long is
astonishing i mean checks on a national
database showed a close match to 90
people which police detectives were able
to whittle down eventually identifying a
relatively fuller before finding the man
himself astonishing and i think it was
something like how many million images
14 million images on his hard drives of
really distressing sexual offenses i
mean this is this is astonishing it's
it's
breathtaking mind-blowing there's not
enough adjectives to describe it david i
thought that yeah
the question on the front page how many
more victims we understand any of us
have covered this type of story
recidivism is a big issue when it comes
to sexual offending and and that is a
very fair question to be asking
yes and i think they i think they're
aware of of 78 identified victims and
they think it could be hundreds more
they they really have no idea i i
thought that uh your colleague jason
farrell's uh interview there with uh the
mother of one of the victims was not
only really powerful and real really
emotional but i actually brought out
those questions very well about they
have no idea about how many victims they
are but also there's been a great
failure there how did
how did this guy get access for so long
to this morgue how was he allowed to
carry this out in secret for so long why
wasn't there proper security or proper
processes in check why weren't these
bodies that should be looked after being
being kept properly re it really is a
case that is not only horrifying but
also raises some troubling questions i
think yeah questions which i'm sure many
papers will be looking to answer at some
point uh count david we will pause there
just briefly coming up after the break
we'll be taking a look at the front of
the telegraph
their headline the prime minister's
pledge ignores tree burning for
electricity we explain that after this
[Music]
welcome back to the papers uh david and
carl still with us well in fact carol's
not i don't know where she's gone david
back to you um let's go to the front
page of the telegraph
good to see you carol sorry we just put
you on the wrong side of the screen uh
david take us to the front of the
telegraph the story on the right there
the prime minister ignoring tree burning
explain this one to me
yeah this this is a story that's on the
front of the the telegraph it's it's
it's raising concerns about uh one of
the pledges one of the big key pledges
made at cop 26 to halt and reverse tree
loss that boris johnson had signed up to
and it's it's flagging up concerns about
uh the uh biomass plant draxon north
yorkshire uh which they are which i
think it burns fuel pellets made from
processed wood which some scientists are
calling you know a fossil fuel really a
for fossil fuel so
they're raising concerns about does this
take into account this that will this be
included in the pledge and i think it's
it's raising the specific issue about
whether this type of plant uh is is
compatible with the pledges being made
at cop26 but i think it also raises that
bigger question that we're
we're having i think i think there's a
generally positive atmosphere at the
minute about what has been achieved at
cop that they're maybe moving towards
achieving a reasonable solution i know
that the climate envoy john kerry was
speaking very positively today in
glasgow about being on the brink of a
real real breakthrough but of course as
of all these uh announcements and all
these types of uh events uh and and
conferences the devil will be in the
detail and it can take some time to
process through exactly what has been
achieved and what the commitments could
mean i think you might have a point
there carol take us to the yorkshire
post and another one of these stories
that is really just
just makes no sense
sorry i don't have it well i don't have
it well what do you make of the english
cricket boards cancelling international
matches being played at headingley after
yorkshire county cricket club well
frankly they didn't get their house in
order i mean this racism scandal has
been around for a couple of days now and
it does rather feel that the ecb
might not have made this decision had
they not been forced into it
well i can tell you all i know having
read it earlier a bit of it earlier
today but have nothing from you guys
it's just that it's been it's bad it's
been um
very sponsors are abandoning them
they're they're not going to be handling
international quicker matches anymore
it's all over the the crisis of their
handling of the azim rafiq racism
scandal where there was an investigation
into that
uh and and it was
he had been called the p name repeatedly
at the club and the investigation
dismissed that as banter now that the
the cricketing world is taking a very
very dim view of this quite rightly and
is telling the club to get his house in
order basically
it does feel like they've had to be
dragged towards that conclusion i think
the the report did find you know there
was uh
serious problems with racism in the club
yet they they didn't they didn't censor
anybody nobody was disciplined and it
has i think really taken a public
backlash a few days of pretty sustained
media coverage uh
key sponsors pulling out and just just a
general a general sense that they're
they're not they haven't dealt with this
appropriately for them to take action
and i think that could really backfire
on them because it's it's going to have
almost more severe consequences now than
it would have done if they've just been
up front from the beginning and said
what the issues have been in the past
and what they were going to do to put
them right yeah it feels like it's a
story that is going to run for just a
little bit longer david carroll good to
see both of you again we will see you
just a little bit later but for now
thanks very much indeed
you